pour tout le monde reçoit tout le monde
arrête du canada le breton bonne année
remise de votre bail bonne wi2wi en fait
surtout revivre ou de l'après bye bye je
me suis un peu retrouvée à rendre la
promotion pour une autre série dans
laquelle je tourne et en même temps br j
ai pu ramasser le espèce de vague de
l'après bye bye vague auquel je ne
m'attendais pas pantoute fait que
c'était assez particulier mais j'en suis
remis à jour tous aujourd'hui au théâtre
d'aujourd'hui pour corps célestes où
vous incarnez le rôle de lilly kate une
réalisatrice de films pornographiques
faudrait que les personnages complexes à
vous allez c'est ce que vous recherchez
pourquoi publicité oui en fait c'est ça
qu'on dit j'ai aucun bug ou défi c'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est de se
sortir de notre zone de confort c'est
d'aller dans des zones inexplorées les
terres de création permet justement
parce qu'on a un univers à créer c'est
très particulier ce trait vertigineux
mais c'est un beau risque et tu fermes
les yeux et j'ai été élevé aux états
unis en suisse parce que votre père
devait voyager
comment cette pérégrination vous a
poussé à faire ce métier de comédienne
qui change un métier en perpétuelle
moore mais peut-être que tu la capacité
de s'adapter à une situation la capacité
de lire chez les autres c'est quoi leur
envie c'est quoi leur humour ses
collants désir c'est que tu dois
développer très jeune quand tu es sans
cesse propulsé dans une bricole et
encore plus quand est propulsé non des
nouvelles cultures fait qu sans devenir
caméléon j'ai su très vite apprendre à
lire les autres pour correspondre à
quelque chose pour
pour être acceptée tout simplement et
sûrement que ça m'a servi ça et le fait
que malheureusement route de ménage est
toujours au début de l'été fait que je
vais toujours me deux mois pas d'amis à
l'islam et où j'ai passé énormément de
temps tout seul à même hanté des mondes
imaginaires à me créer des univers qui
n'existait pas à moto suffira départ et
proment de là est né le plaisir du jeu
et le plaisir de se raconter des
histoires c'est quand même une question
de survie
quand eto'o 81e seulement donné mais
c'est clair c'est lui qui écrit la
lettre c'est tout à fait son genre il
veut se venger de moi vous avez vraiment
commencé votre carrière avec ouattata
tarifs mais vraiment le point tournant
pour vous ça a été un beau mariage ça me
stresse tailor is rich et encore moins
comment vous étiez la conjointe de selex
à décoller au niveau marin mais ç'a
toujours des clés et j'ai toujours
travaillé était avant les bouclages
avait fait mauvais karma j'avais
septième manche j'avais joué j'avais
fait plein de choses
ce que ça a changé les boues malaise
c'est la notoriété c'est compliqué et ça
coûte avec cette notoriété là est venu
la possibilité de se faire offrir des
projets ou d'être associés à des trucs
peut-être s'en passer d'audition cela
dit je passe encore des auditions mais
ça a quand même un petit peu ouvert les
portes du système je dirais on sait pas
encore ce que provoquer les toxiques à
sion alimentaire monsieur le ministre
les analyses sont en cours dans la série
fut démis j'ai lu ça quelque part vous
incarnez aux médecins je doute que c'est
un rêve de jeunesse mais parce que je
voulais être médecin légiste moi j'avais
des grands fantasmes médicaux je t'aime
facilitera les choses mais tout cas
jusqu'à l'âge de 12 mais je conseille à
challans en peul au cégep et et c'est là
que mon rêve s'est écroulé tel un
château de cartes
saoud et porte les chances pour voir les
portes de ne pas l'aimer cours et de
faire du social à place et mais ça m'a
surtout fait réaliser que je serais
beaucoup plus heureuse ailleurs dans une
école de théâtre
mais oui je voulais être médecin je sais
pas si c'est la réalité de la chance
d'une espèce de ses pages je trouvais
cela mais je crois mais maintenant que
j'ai côtoyé plusieurs médecins et le
milieu hospitalier je sais quel point
ces gens là travaillent fort et qu'elle
veut c'est des gens dévoués et qu'ils
doivent faire preuve de tellement
sang-froid sang froid je n'aurais jamais
été capable de parler non pas 200 francs
chez vous mais pas dans des situations
de crise quand la vie de quelqu'un est
entre mes mains mes patins c'est
l'adrénaline qui vous attirait la sadur
langue c'est à être oui ou trop de films
médicaux que j'ai regardé quand je
trouve peut-être mais ma mère est
infirmière donc médecins et infirmières
si on aime sol j'ai jamais su prendre
soin des gens comme ça quelques malheurs
james hall lui donner le médicament
approprié quand c'est légal mais sauf
jules à breton merci beaucoup c'est un
plaisir merci
[Musique]
deux années en option
j'ai french et julie le breton ouais à
qui tu veux savoir si je veux dénoncer
moi aussi je veux d'abord nos jours
monde devait retourner prochaines
semaines
[Musique]